-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
the "Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
You're here.
You're watching the right show.
Thank you.
-Love you, Jimmy!
-Well -- I love you, too.
[ Light laughter ]
Well, guys, one of the biggest
movies of the year,
"Spider-Man: No Way Home"
has finally hit theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally.
Fans are going nuts.
People haven't been this pumped
for a Marvel movie
since the last one
came out a week ago.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, everyone's excited
to see it in theaters.
Even Dr. Fauci was like,
"Screw it.
I got to support this guy."
[ Laughter ]
"He's wearing a mask.
Let's go. I'm ready to go."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, as we speak,
fans are lined up
to see the movie,
including plenty of guys
dressed like Spider-Man
who definitely can't pull off
dressing like Spider-Man.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
In this movie,
Spider-Man has to fight off
a bunch of crazy villains
at once.
And after he does,
he's immediately hired
as a flight attendant
for United.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of airlines,
in a Senate hearing,
the CEOs of Southwest
and American Airlines
both questioned the need
for masks on planes.
Yep, the same thing
actually happened last month
with the CEO of Spirit
and pants.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the Southwest CEO was
like, "Who needs masks?
There's plenty of fresh air.
We fly with the top down."
"Buckle up, everybody!"
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of wearing masks
on planes, I heard about
one passenger who tried
work around the rule.
Listen to this.
-A man is now banned from flying
with United Airlines
after deciding to mask up
with a bright red thong.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-If you fly Spirit,
that's the oxygen mask
that drops down in an emergency.
[ Laughter ]
Make sure to put it
on yourself first, then...
[ Laughter ]
-"Dumps like a truck."
-A few minutes later,
an air marshal walked over
and gave him a mouth wedgie.
It was interesting.
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this?
Former President Trump
is really upset with his old
chief of staff Mark Meadows
for writing in his book
that Trump's hair
looked awful when he had COVID.
[ Laughter ]
Must have looked really bad,
because that's how most people
describe Trump's hair
when he's healthy.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I read
that this holiday season,
Melania Trump is releasing
her first NFT,
called "Melania's Vision,"
which is a watercolor
of her eyes.
[ Laughter ]
Donald's like,
"I'm so proud of you.
Congrats on the 'nuft.'"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump's excited about it.
He thinks NFT stands
for "not filing taxes."
[ Laughter and applause ]
The cool thing
about Melania's NFT,
just like she does
with her husband,
as soon as you turn away,
the eyes roll.
[ Laughter ]
It's amazing.
Hey, this is cool.
In a recent interview,
Usain Bolt said
that playing "Mario Kart"
helped him become
an Olympic champion.
[ Cheers ]
I'm in shock.
'Cause apparently I've been
training for the Olympics
for the last 35 years.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this.
Here in New York, an MTA manager
was caught with the blow-up doll
in the front seat of his car,
and he's insisting that
he uses it for the company
and not so that he can drive
in the carpool lane.
[ Laughter ]
In a related story, he's lying.
Guy was like, "Look,
if you have a problem with this,
talk to my lawyer," and then,
he blew up another doll.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, guys, "Sing 2"
is coming out next week.
I mean,
we are excited about this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It has such an amazing cast,
and we wanted to do something
fun with the actors.
So we gave them a bunch
of weird phrases
and asked them to sneak those
phrases into their interviews
as casually as possible.
No one knew we were doing this.
So check it out.
It's time for "Drop It In."
-♪ Drop It In, Drop It In ♪
♪ D-D-D-D-Drop It In, yeah ♪
-Obviously, everyone's going
to watch "Sing 2" for Christmas.
How do you guys plan on
celebrating Christmas
this year?
-I'm just going to eat
a lot of food, I feel like,
'cause, you know,
you know what they say --
if you can't lick the spoon,
just eat the bowl, you know?
-That's right.
-Which of the following
is not a marsupial --
kangaroo, koala, or platypus?
-Koala.
-Platypus have no pouches.
They're the only
egg-laying mammal.
-Pouches, eggs,
grape nuts, go nuts.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-I think it's also a movie
about --
about overcoming your own
personal obstacles and --
I mean, even the Pringles Guy
gets lonely in January.
-How many "Sing" stories
do you want to tell?
Like, have you thought
of what you would write
for "Sing 3" or "Sing 4"?
-There could be a "Sing 3,"
"Sing 4," "Sing 5," "Sing 6,"
"Sing 7," "Sing 8" --
"Sing 8," yeah -- "Sing 9,"
"Sing 10," "Sing 11,"
-It'd be like the KIDZ BOP
version of movies!
-..."Sing 12." Yeah! I mean,
you'd skip 13 because of,
you know, bad vibes.
-Yeah, no, you can never...
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But, no, I think, otherwise,
it could go on forever.
-So, this was obviously,
like, filming during the pand--
Did you guys get to get together
at any point?
-Oh!
They're g-r-r-rape!
As T the Tiger says.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're g-r-rape!
-That's sort of the fun
of show business.
And the hard part is, you know,
you get ready, and then there's
someone who can tell you no,
and it's deflating, you know?
It's never a great idea
to microwave a balloon.
[ Ding ]
...and I think that the beauty
of this cast of characters is,
they don't stop.
-In the film, Buster Moon has
to tell a little white lie.
I'm curious to know
if you've ever had to exaggerate
a special skill to either land
a role or get ahead.
-I never will tell a white lie.
And that's something I learned
when I once
put a balloon
inside of a microwave,
and it's never a good idea to
put a balloon in a microwave.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just have
one last thing to say.
Nunca es un buen idea poner
un globo en el microondo.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that's something that is
really important to remember.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you
for sharing that tip with us.
-Guys, we have exactly
two shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
-♪ "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters" ♪
♪ Two days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an absurdly cool
Christmas sweater from the
Countdown to
Christmas Cabinet.
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...since there are
two shows left,
let's open door number 2.
Where is door number 2?
Wow!
[ Drum roll ]
Whenever you're ready.
Yeah! It's Santa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Look at that.
Whoa! That's a lot of
sweater right there.
Oh, it's gorgeous.
Look at that.
Can you turn it around?
Oh, look at that. Come on.
That's high quality right there.
Now let's see who's gonna go
home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone,
look at your seat number.
And if I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
Who wants this sweater?
It's a good one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
232!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on down.
♪♪
Well, hello!
-Hi.
-Welcome. What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Abby Lane, from
Nashville, Tennessee.
-Yeah!
From Nashville, Tennessee.
We love Nashville.
Well, sometimes, it gets cool,
it gets cozy up there
in Nashville.
-Sure.
-Would you like to try
this on for the audience...
-I absolutely would.
-...just so everyone can see
how beautiful it looks.
I think this perfect.
♪♪
No one will have
this in Nashville.
-No.
-No, no, no.
Probably any state you go to,
they won't have it.
Tenness-- Oh!
Oh, wow. Look at it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is fant-- Look at that.
You look gorgeous.
Oh, oh, my -- Yes!
Oh, my goodness.
Fantastic! Thank you so much.
Congrats to our winner.